قال مستشار الأمن القومي الأمريكي جيك
سوليفان إن البيت الأبيض لا
يتوقع أن تواصل إسرائيل
حصارا كاملا على قطاع غزة، كما أمر وزير الدفاع يوم
الاثنين، وما زالت
إمدادات الكهرباء مقطوعة وكذلك
إمدادات المياه، وفي الوقت الحالي تتسبب الضربات الجوية الإسرائيلية في
أضرار جسيمة لقطاع غزة.
فرصة ماثيو من سي إن إن في تقريرنا من
القدس عبر غزة، إسرائيل
تطلق العنان
لغضبها بعد قصف ميناء غزة الصغير من
الجو، ويقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إن أكثر من
2000 هدف في هذه المنطقة المكتظة بالسكان،
بما في ذلك المباني السكنية
والمساجد، قد تم
تدميرها في الهجمات الأخيرة التي
شنتها حماس مما أدى إلى تدمير
رد فعل مدمر وفي غزة، إنه دموي
أيضًا، حيث يحفر الفلسطينيون بين
أنقاض المباني المسطحة مع ارتفاع عدد القتلى،
ويقول مسؤولو الصحة هناك إن أكثر
من 900 شخص قُتلوا حتى الآن
[موسيقى]
قُتل أبنائي الثلاثة
مع زوجاتهم و  كان هناك ما
يقرب من 50 شهيدًا في هذا
المبنى، ويقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه
انتشل جثث 1500
فلسطيني آخرين اقتحموا
الأراضي الإسرائيلية ويطاردون الآن نشطاء حماس
الجماعيين، ولن يكون لديهم مكان
للاختباء في غزة، مقابل هذا المتحدث العسكري الإسرائيلي،
سنصل إليهم في أي مكان يتواجد فيه.
يصر وهذا قد يعني المضي قدماً بشكل أكثر
جدية، فقد نشرت إسرائيل بالفعل
قوات واستدعت مئات
الآلاف من قوات الاحتياط
استعدادًا واضحًا لهجوم بري،
لكن غزة ليست فقط واحدة من
أكثر المناطق كثافة سكانية في العالم، بل
يتقاطع معها أيضًا طريق مخفي
محتمل.  شبكة من
الأنفاق المفخخة التي يستخدمها المسلحون للتحرك
دون أن يتم اكتشافها عبر
المنطقة، فإن الهجوم البري الإسرائيلي المتوقع على نطاق واسع
على غزة، إذا حدث،
سيكون محفوفًا بالمخاطر أيضًا.
في إطار
الاستعداد لتوغل محتمل في
غزة، رأينا دبابات تطلق النار في تلك
المنطقة هناك، نحن على بعد حوالي 2 ميل
من سياج غزة ولم نشاهد
دبابات تطلق النار هناك قبل أه وقبل ذلك
بقليل هذا المساء  كذلك كنا
نسمع تبادلاً
لإطلاق النار من أسلحة رشاشة ثقيلة على بعد حوالي ميل ونصف من
ذلك الطريق مباشرة فوق
التل هناك مجتمع صغير هناك،
واكتشفت قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية
ثلاثة من نشطاء حماس في زنزانة هناك
واشتبكوا في قتال عنيف هناك.
كانت قنابل مضيئة تم وضعها في السماء لإعطاء
رؤية أفضل للمنطقة، ولكن في
نهاية تلك المعركة، تم تحييد نشطاء حماس الثلاثة
باستخدام
تعبير ملطف لقوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية، مما يشير مرة أخرى
إلى حقيقة أن هناك
المزيد من القوات على الأرض.
بدأت في العثور على آخر بقايا
بقايا حماس من عطلة نهاية الأسبوع،
إذا صح التعبير، فإن عملاء حماس الذين جاءوا
عبر الحدود في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع لم
يعودوا، لقد ظلوا صامدين الآن
ويتم اكتشافهم ولكن هذه
المنطقة بأكملها الآن أصبحت  عملية أمنية مشددة واسعة النطاق
هنا ونحن نرى المزيد والمزيد من
القوات الثقيلة أه قطع المدفعية الثقيلة آه مدافع
الهاوتزر الثقيلة تحفر في الحقول
هنا وقد سمعنا
مدافع الهاوتزر خلال المساء تطلق
قذائف على غزة وتضرب أه
مواقع إطلاق تلك الصواريخ التي نحن'  لقد تم
إطلاق الصواريخ في عدة مناسبات خارج غزة،
مثل عمليات الاعتراض من القبة الحديدية
التي تجري فوق هنا، الشعور برمته
هنا هو التوتر، المزيد من الأمن،
المزيد من القوات بوتيرة سريعة، الآن
هناك هدوء، لكنك لا تعرف أبدًا
كيف  يمكن أن يستمر الهدوء لفترة طويلة أو ما
سينتج عنه المزيد من
القصف العنيف والمزيد من الضربات الصاروخية أم هذا
وضع متقلب للغاية